SPEAKER 1: Ideas never
translate automatically
into political action.
They have to be
embodied in persons.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
By the late-1970s, the structure
of a conservative alternative
to elements of
Democratic orthodoxy
were clearly emerging
around certain principles
of smaller government
with lower taxes,
a relatively free economy
with a minimum of regulation,
and opposition to communism.
On all of these points and
more, the burgeoning movement
found a winning spokesman
in Ronald Reagan,
whose presidential
time had at last come
in 1980 after several
previous attempts.
But Reagan was more
than just a vehicle
for other people's ideas.
Ideas never translate
automatically
into political action.
They have to be
embodied in persons.
And Reagan's persona gave a
particular cast to the ideas
that he propounded.
He was a superbly
gifted speaker who
had experience as a movie actor
and a television performer.
He was entering into
a television age
he was the master of.
HENRY TREWHITT: Mr.
President, I want
to raise an issue that I think
has been lurking out there
for two or three weeks
and cast it specifically
in national security terms.
You already are the oldest
president in history,
and some of your
staff say you were
tired after your most recent
encounter with Mr. Mondale.
I recall yet that
President Kennedy
had to go for days on end
with very little sleep
during the Cuban Missile Crisis.
Is there any doubt
in your mind that you
would be able to function
in such circumstances?
RONALD REAGAN: Not
at all, Mr. Trewhitt.
And I want you to know that
also I will not make age
an issue of this campaign.
I am not going to exploit
for political purposes
my opponent's youth
and inexperience.
[LAUGHTER]
[APPLAUSE]
SPEAKER 1: He had to run
against Jimmy Carter.
Carter was no match for Reagan
in the 1980 campaign-- and not
only because Carter's
record in office
had been so poor and
so difficult to defend.
Reagan offered a vision that
was more hopeful than Carter's.
In his inauguration
address that day,
Reagan blamed government
itself for many of the nation's
problems and proposed
that a more open,
less heavily regulated,
less heavily taxed
economy would produce growth.
The other principal
goal of Reagan
was to rebuild the nation's
standing in the world
after the humiliations
of Vietnam and Iran.
And waging the Cold War
with the Soviet Union
required a more effective
and decisive American policy.
As he said once, here's my
strategy on the Cold War--
we win and they lose.
That view never changed,
although the details
filled themselves out
in different ways.
The Soviet Union
was an evil empire.
It was the focus of evil
in the modern world.
He lambasted and
mocked communism
for its many failures, its
cruelty, its inefficiency,
its disdain for human rights,
its incompetence, its atheism.
He increased
spending on defense,
put into production a variety
of new defense systems--
the B-1 bomber, the
MX land-based missile.
He built a 600-ship
American Navy.
And most intriguing of
all, he started work
on what was called the Strategic
Defense Initiative, or SDI,
which critics called Star
Wars, because it used
lasers and particle beams
to shoot down incoming enemy
missiles.
The critics said
it wouldn't work.
And even if it did
work, it would only
fuel another round of the
arms race this time in space.
The Euro Missile Crisis,
as it was called,
was a turning point.
And in the Soviet
Union, the ascent
of Mikhail Gorbachev
as Party Secretary,
General Secretary of
the Communist Party.
There began a conspicuous change
in tone of Soviet leadership.
Gorbachev wanted to
reform Soviet life.
He wanted to open it up.
He wanted to restructure it.
Reagan grasped the
opportunities presented
by this change in power, worked
with Gorbachev favorably.
Although he was insistent that
words be followed by deeds.
When he spoke at the
Brandenburg Gate in West Berlin
at the Berlin Wall--
RONALD REAGAN: General
Secretary Gorbachev,
if you seek peace, if you seek
prosperity for the Soviet Union
and Eastern Europe, if
you seek liberalization,
come here to this gate.
Mr. Gorbachev, open this gate.
[CHEERING]
Mr. Gorbachev.
Mr. Gorbachev, tear
down this wall.
[CHEERING]
SPEAKER 1: Of course,
Gorbachev did not oblige him
in this regard, but he
did negotiate a treaty
to abolish intermediate
range nuclear missiles,
first time the two
nations had agreed
to eliminate an entire
class of weapon,
a move that would have been
unthinkable without Reagan's
firmness in the
Euro Missile Crisis.
SPEAKER 2: Thank
you for watching.
We hope you're enjoying
our Highlights series
and invite you to explore
all of Hillsdale College's
online courses.
They are free and for
everyone who loves to learn.